hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're going to
be starting our series on the 1997
rematch between Gary Kasparov and the
IBM supercomputer deep blue now if you
remember from 1996 our series Gary
Kasparov
at that time again the reigning world
champion won this series four to two and
so IBM went back to the lab did some
tweaks of their computer and said ok we
now have a bigger better stronger faster
supercomputer deep blue is now ready to
take on the number one human at the time
gierek's Bharath and so that's what we
have garrix bob accepted the challenge
in 1997 they met to play to see who was
still the champion now format is still
the same they're going to be playing six
chess games they'll be switching off
your X prov would go first in the first
game he would play white and then they
would you know switch back and forth the
blue would play black and so forth and
so forth and at the end of it if there's
a winner that would be deemed the winner
if not they would move on from there so
in the first game we're going to be
going over to Game one again the 1997
rematch between Gary Kasparov and deep
blue why it's going to be played by
garrix Roth and black is going to be
played by IBM supercomputer deep blue
why it's going to start out with Knight
to f3 ready opening gives a lot of
flexibility to Garry Kasparov to go into
whatever opening or middle game he
chooses to D blue is going to respond
with pawn to d5 and we have pawn to g3
get Iran to think into his Bishop here
to g2 then the bishop is going to come
down to g4 getting his minor pieces
involved White's going to play pawn to
b3 followed by Knight to d7 that would
be completely ok if you're looking at me
say you know why is the knight come here
to d7 again there's so many different
variations black could have done many
different things he could have brought
his night down to c6 that would have
been completely fine you could have
played his Knight to f6 this is kind of
one of those black already has his
LightSquared bishop involved into the
game so he doesn't have to worry about
blocking that so he can bring his knight
here to d7 and be completely ok you know
controlling these dark squares here on
e5 and c5 so why it's going to continue
with Bishop to b2 again this is kind of
a hyper modern defense where white tries
to control this
the board with his minor pieces and then
later on into the board
Laidlaw into the game he's going to try
to push his pawns forward and control it
and as you can see why it's going to
transpose into a Kings Indian attack so
it's not the typical hyper aggressive
Kasparov that many of us have seen over
time but this is an opening that you
know Bobby Fischer played a lot
it's definitely strong and it gives
white a lot of opportunities to go in a
lot of different directions you know
again garrix Bob's not tying him to any
particular open he can kind of go into
the middle game however he wants to it's
very flexible opening blacks going to
play pawn to e6 and then why she's going
to continue develop his pieces being
ketamine's Bishop here on g2 then that's
going to come to f6
simple development getting all your
pieces getting ready to attack the
center of the board why it's going to
castle and then blacks going to play
pawn to c6 now if you played the slob
defense semi Slav this is what you'll
see a lot you'll have this pawn here on
you know c6 pawn on d5 and the pawn here
on e6 you know black decided to go ahead
and bring his light to her Bishop
involved into the game first but you
know connecting these nights here on d7
f6 granted you typically see the Slav in
the semi Slav against the Queen's Gambit
which it would be you know d4 to start
the game and then c4 but you know it's
still plays you know fairly well against
this type of opening the only difference
would be you know against the Queen's
Gambit blacks trying to play a little
more defensive and then try to
counter-attack where in this particular
game black even though he has kind of a
defensive stance here he actually has
more initiative since White's playing
even more conservative he hasn't moved
any of his pieces or pawns past the
third-ranked so it'll kind of be more of
a you know an attacking Slav you know
defense if you're familiar with this
lava thing white now plays pawn to d3
again still leaving him a lot of
different options he can always you know
play e4 if he wants to he can bring his
knight here to c3 and attack the center
of the board and then play Queen to d2
completing his development connecting
his rooks on the on the last row he
could always bring his knight here to d2
connecting his knight so again allowing
himself for a lot of different options
and then the bishop is going to come
here to d6
and the slob defense you typically want
to get your dark-squared bishop
centralized so it just has a lot of
different options and then white plays
Knight to d2 now white does have a lot
of different options here he could
always you know start to attack on the
Queen side he could be a little more
aggressive if he wanted you know he
could try something like you know pawn
here to see for this is going to be
completely okay and then he could now
bring his knight here to c3 after he's
pushed that pawn garrix barb decides to
play a little safer kind of build up all
of his pieces connect them so he brings
his knight over here to d2 connecting it
here to this knight on f3 now white
blacks going to castle and then White's
going to push his pawn forward to h3
kicking this Bishop back you know early
on you don't see high-level players
giving up their bishops for a knight so
the bishop is just going to come back
here to h5 and then the Y it's going to
push forward to e3 we still have not
seen a piece or a pawn move past that
third rank for garrix prop so again he's
just kind of waiting he now has a little
place this Queen can come here to e2 if
he wants to he's probably going to want
to move this so it's not pinned down by
this knight anymore but just giving him
you know a few more options now Black's
gonna play pawn to h6 and White's gonna
play Queen over here to h1 wants to make
sure that his Knights not being pinned
or his Queens not not being pinned down
by this night here I'm this Bishop here
on h5 and now the Queen's going to come
over here to a5 now White has a few
different options I you know I kind of
like just the pawn to e4 I think this
gives him you know a lot of fighting
opportunities he's really dominating the
sin of the board right here um he
decides to play pawn to a3 um you know I
I don't know if I would play that you
know it's garrix bar so you know he can
kinda what he wants to he's the best
chess player in the world at the time
but I do think he has more opportunity
to attack and you know with this Queen
over here on a5 you know it's not doing
a whole lot if he plays you know pawn
here to e4 I think that would be a
little stronger move but he's had to
play pawn to a3 the bishop comes back
here to c7
getting ready to defend this Queen here
on a5 and then giving me for some other
attack so the Knights going to come over
here to h4 this is the first time that
white has played a piece or upon pass
this this third rank here the pawns
going to immediately come down here to
g5 kicking that night off again this is
one of those moves there's a few moves
throughout the game that you know
probably could have gone a different way
and completely change the outcome of the
game this is putting a lot of air you
know in front of this King right here
and so you know anytime your pawns are
pushing too forward in front of your
king you're leaving a lot of room now
you won't see it right away as far as
the payoff because there's no pieces or
pawns or moved off the board so garrix
fob just can't swoop in right away and
start attacking the King but as you'll
see there's there's just all this room
in here and slowly over time gierek's
fob is going to be able to take
advantage of that and find weakness so
he decides okay I'm just going to move
my knight back here to f3 that was
completely worth it to go ahead and move
it here and then have this pawn come
down here to g5 black now plays his pawn
to e5 getting ready if there's a center
attacking is pieces and pawns ready and
that white decides to go ahead and play
that move pawn to e4 saying okay I'm now
ready to attack I have all my pieces
exactly where I want them so I'm ready
to go here and black decides he's
developed all of his pieces and now he
can start to get his rooks you know you
want to connect to rooks and then you
want to get them behind your pawns or to
send me open files open files he decides
to bring his rook over here to e8 as
you'll see later on he'll also get his
other rook involved into the game you
really want them to play a supporting
role kind of in that middle game and
then late-game your major pieces your
Queen's in your rook start to take over
the game and start to do more so from
here White's going to play his Knight
over to h2 it's not doing a whole lot so
he kind of wants to you know later on
get it into a better position he could
move forward with g4 probably even
smarter if he just played you know g4 if
he had you know more support there but
just giving him
options you really didn't like it here
on f3 so blac decided to bring his queen
over here to b6 attacking this pawn here
on f2 not a whole lot of attack
so why didn't have to worry about it too
much he decides to come over here and
bring his Queen to c1 you know he does
have different options you know I don't
know if that's the best move but you
know he decides to go ahead and play it
blacks him go and come down and bring
his pawn to a5 and why it's going to go
ahead and bring his rook over here to e1
so he wants to go ahead and open up this
f1 square so that he can go ahead and
you know attach it to this D 2 square
also if he wants to go ahead and bring
his you know Knight here to d3 or excuse
me
III he has that opportunity as well now
the bishop is going to come down to d6
getting ready to come to c5 and attack
this pawn here on f2 which is kind of a
weakness for white early on since you
know he only right now has his king
that's protecting this pond so huge
weakness early on for white is this f2
square and for black it's it's typically
the f7 Square
now the Knights going to come over here
to to f1 getting ready to protect this
square here on a3 he can go ahead and
jump there when he wants to blacks are
going to go ahead and take here on e4
and whites just going to take back and
then the bishop is going to come here to
c5 as we talked about
now from here White's going to play
Knight to e3 and we've reached equality
so if you look at both sides you know
black has one goal any time he's playing
black and that is to reach equality
meaning that both sides should have
around equal opportunity to win the game
so black is doing a really good job he
has all of his pieces developed into the
game he has a strong you know center
attack if you look at white all this
pieces are really working together I
mean has this dark squared bishop that
his you know eying down on this long
diagonal black does have a little more
air in front of his King so it's going
to be a little easier for white to
attack this later on to the game and all
of whites pieces you know there's
nothing wrong with them it's still going
to be very difficult for black to to
find a weakness here
because all this pieces and pawns are
very well defended from here deep blue
plays rook to d8 again this is now a
completely open file so black decides
you know right away let's go ahead and
get that that rook over here which is a
great move anytime you're looking for
moves you know you want to have your
rooks connected you want to bring them
anyway there's a semi-open or completely
open meaning there's there's no pawns in
the way file so that's exactly what he
does and then the pawn or excuse me the
knight comes over here to f1 protecting
this night here on e3 and then black
plays pawn to g4 now later on into the
game we'll start to look at some
questionable moves but I think this is
really where black you know starts to
give up his position is we you know just
a couple moves ago we said black had
reached equality black head in my
opinion a really easy move to look at
when you're looking at the board you
want to look at pieces or pawns that are
you know over attacked and under
defended and so he could you know played
Bishop to g6 here there's now two
attackers on this pawn on e4 there's
only one defender it's going to force
white to respond to this white can't be
you know really attacking from here he's
kind of in that defense mode which is
what black wants to do but instead of
playing this he keeps his Bishop here on
h5 which is not doing a whole heck of a
lot and instead plays pawn to g4 giving
even more air in front of this King
which which is really going to be
difficult later on so white decides to
go ahead and play you know takes here on
d4 and then after the knight takes here
on g4 then the pawn is just going to
move forward to f3 now White has to be
careful because this Knight is now being
pinned down to the King and since black
has both his Queen here and his Bishop
here on c5 running down here it
definitely has to keep notice of that
but there's just going to be some
exchanges here after the Knights
exchange then the bishops going to come
back here to e7 now white decides right
away he wants to make sure that you know
his pieces are not pinned down anymore
so he immediately brings his King
over here to h1 and then the bishop
comes over here to g5 now this is
important for black because he
recognizes you know he being the
computer IBM supercomputer uh-huh but
the computer recognizes okay and keep in
mind the supercomputer probably thought
about this you know 12 moves ahead but
he realized that his pawn on the g5 was
gone he had overextended it for one
reason or another and it was very
important that he brings something back
here to protect it or it was going to be
very bad for him so he found a nice
little outpost here on g5 being
protected by this pawn on h6 and it's
kind of serving as that you know pawn
protection in front of the king here now
White's going to play rook to e2 and
black follows with his pawn here to e4
RA for saying you know hey I want to
attack on the King side if you want to
let me why decides you know I don't even
want to worry about that let's just go
ahead and play pawn here to b4 and then
black starts to push forward so he
recognizes that he you know his King
side is kind of blown up so he's gonna
try to counter-attack on the King side
and blow up the King side for white
White's just going to recapture here on
f5 and then blacks going to push forward
with his pawn on e4 now this is where
gierek's parob is phenomenal and really
shines is because he looks at this and
he says okay you know I have my rook
here on e2 but the King side for black
is is really really weak right now so
I'm going to go ahead and play pawn to
f4 which black immediately played Bishop
takes the rook here on e2 but then the
pawn is going to recapture here on g5
now this is extremely important because
you know Garrick spot now has two pawns
right here that are going to be really
hard to deal with now just so we're
clear black really can't recapture here
on g5 and I'll kind of show you why
white can now play Knight to c4 now this
is a extremely powerful move because it
opens the door for the Queen to come
here too
- you know g5 if the bishop were to take
here on you know c4 then when the Queen
came here the next move for why it's
going to be checkmate there's nothing
that black can do to stop this now if we
look at and say okay you know obviously
they don't want that to happen but you
know after the knight comes here he's
attacking this the only thing that black
can do to save this checkmate over here
is to lose his queen here so he would
end up losing his Queen on b6 this would
definitely not be good black would be so
far down the material so gears prop saw
this and say okay I'm gonna have my pawn
on f5 and g5 and black can't recapture
so instead black plays you know Knight
to e5 and this is important move because
it blocks off this long diagonal from
the dark squared bishop which is where
that mating pattern came from but garrix
prob can now play pawn to g6 and you
know it's really hard to to look at
something and say you know does a
supercomputer not understand the
significance or the importance of you
know a passed pawn that's protected by
another pawn here both past the fourth
rank this is extremely valuable you know
he looked at that and so maybe this
could be the supercomputer said I would
rather be up a rook and give up a bishop
and I can just deal with this but garrix
parcelled a little bit differently and
so that's kind of what we have right
here black now plays Bishop to f3 now
this is a good move I do disagree that
black allowed this to happen up here
giving this protected passed pawn but
the bishop here on f3 is is a great
square and if you're always watching
these games trying to figure out where
you should go for your minor pieces you
always want to have an outpost and a
bishop down here on the third rank you
know being protected by a pawn here on
e4 this is a great outpost for this
Bishop he can just kind of hanging out
here all day if the bishop were to take
here it's also a great outpost for the
night he can recapture here on f3 and
have a great great square for his minor
pieces so this was a great move White's
now going to play Bishop to c3 he wants
to make sure he still controls this long
day
agonal but he recognizes there's one
place that you want your rooks and it's
on your opponent's 2nd or 7th rank so
black eventually would like to play you
know his rook down to d2 not right away
it would be captured obviously but
eventually I mean why would you know he
would like his rook on the seventh rank
for black so this is kind of a waiting
movement at the same time it's just
giving him better position getting his
bishop here to c3 now Black's going to
play you know his Queen here to b5
getting ready to bring his queen to e2
and then swing over here
once this Knight was removed but giving
him a lot of potential to attack this
King over here why decides to go ahead
and bring his Queen over here to f1 his
Queens not doing a whole heck of a lot
so he doesn't mind exchanging black
decides to go in exchange and that's
completely ok with Gary Spock because
now he can not worry about this Queen
and now he has his
you know a1 rook involved into the game
now the pawns going to push forward with
h5 and then garrix Bob's going to bring
his King over to do g1 he wants to now
get his king balled into the game start
to you know take some of this pressure
off as we talked about if the bishop
came here and attacked then the knight
can take back here so he wants to make
sure that he gets his ki involved into
the game and stops any shenanigans so if
you know the bishop came here and took
then he could take with his King if he
wanted to he could take with his knight
he has a lot of different options now
the king is going to come over here to
f8 it's extremely important that that
you know the King kind of stays back
here you know he can let his rooks do a
lot of the action so the bishop is now
going to come here to h3 and then the
pawns are going to come here to b5 just
kind of solidifying this pawn chain not
doing a whole lot it's kind of a
whatever move doesn't really help since
all the actions going on the King side
you know but whatever now the King is
going to come here to f2 and then the
King is going to come here to g7 and
this is really where black starts to
continue to you know fall further and
further behind this King to g7 move you
know if we look a few moves back he
moved his King from g8 to f8 and then he
decided okay there's a lot going on I
really need to make sure all my pieces
are ready I have this protected passed
pawn on g7 I'm now going to move my King
to g7 it's just very questionable you
know he could have IBM could have easily
played you know his rook to d6 you know
attacking this protected pest pawn
putting a lot of pressure on it he could
have gotten his other rook involvement
to the game this would be so much better
for black it's going to be very hard for
white two to really find a continuation
that's that's easily winnable but
instead black decides to just kind of
move his King around in the board not
really do a whole lot so y decides okay
I'm just going to start pushing forward
and so now the King comes to h6 and this
may be an even worse move that the Kings
just not doing a whole lot and so why
he's trying to get involved into the
game completely separated from the rest
of his pieces I have no idea he should
really be looking for his rooks to get
involved start putting them behind
pieces or pawns and start to look for a
strong attack here because this is this
is not going to go well for this King so
now the Rickson come over here to g1
recognizing that there's about to be a
lot of action if there are some
exchanges humans make sure that his
pieces are protected and so that's
exactly what happens the the pawn takes
here on g4 and then exchanges back and
forth the bishop takes the bishop takes
the knight takes the knight takes and
then the rook takes here on g4 as you
can see this is although white is down
in material you know black is a little
better because he has two rooks here on
the d8 file and on the semi-open II file
very strong but White has this you know
pass pawn here now has a passed pawn on
the F file and this is all of White's
pieces are working together all you know
working with these pass pawns
there's there's no way that black can
stop this now black decides to go ahead
and bring his his rook down here to d5
which is an okay move
wants to stop it you know as best he can
if this pawn were to push forward any
more he could swing his you know rook
over here to to f5 attacking both the
the King in the pond so kind of giving
himself some options he's you know IBM
supercomputer deep blues finally
figuring out that he needs to actually
get these rooks involved into the game
he can't just dance around with his King
all day because his King is just kind of
on the sidelines just allowing white to
push up the board there's no reason for
that King to be here on h6 and white
decides to go ahead and push forward
with with f6 and black has a lot of
different options and he supercomputer
deep blue decided to choose the worst
option and that is to bring his rook
down to d1 which does absolutely nothing
there there's no benefit gained at all
there were so many different options
that he could have played you know we
talked about some others but he could
have just brought his rook over here to
g8 that would have definitely been
better stopping something but instead
you know he played rook to d1 and then
immediately gear expire played pawn to
g7 and black was forced to resign
there's really no way for black to stop
anything now in his rook on d1 move
didn't do anything and it was
interesting after the game although it
was a horrible move this d1 move
completely perplexed Kasparov he was
just completely confused I'm going to
had no idea he kind of thought that the
you know computer was was trolling him
almost had no idea why this move was
played but you know as we talked about
before this Bishop on c3 is very very
powerful because the knight can't come
here to be too so
Gary Kasparov played a fantastic game
you know that one point he gave up his
his rook for a bishop just so he could
get these these pawns of here for a
protected past pawn his vision to see it
to the end of the game knowing that
black would not be able to you know stop
this later on just phenomenal especially
against a supercomputer that you know
for the past year the entire idea IBM
team had just been trying to figure out
how to get this machine to be karakov so
game one phenomenal gierek spot goes up
one to zero
we'll be continuing our series later on
going through the other matches in this
series but hope you guys enjoyed this
video feel free to let me know what you
guys think and I'll see you in the next
video thanks for watching